so it's time for a good old-fashioned
audience talent show
i am honored to announce my esteemed
fellow judges our first judge is known
to many as the mayor of broadway that's
right he's an expert in all things
musical theater and it's sirius xm
broadway host seth rogen
thank you and you know he's too legit to
quit ross matthews
this is so exciting for us on our end
and we can't wait to see what you guys
do so we pluck three people from our
audience who are about to perform on
this very stage and let's have some fun
and see what people can do we're going
to vote on a winner who will be coming
home with this state-of-the-art trophy
[Music]
but i mean seth you performed on a stage
a screen or an accomplished pianist um
have you ever done anything like a
talent show
why yes i have um
when i was a kid i won most outstanding
act for playing hide and e minor piano
sonata anybody nobody um yeah i know i
didn't do that okay ross have you ever
performed an italian you know it's a
shame i never did i did put together a
whole routine in fourth grade with
kristen nelson hi girl uh we were gonna
do i had the time of my life from dirty
dancing but when my mother saw it she
thought it was inappropriate i think
i think i really committed to the dirty
part of the dirty dancing and since i
was in fourth grade everyone was
uncomfortable so
i actually was a revelation it's a shame
you'll miss out little rossi dirty
dancing thank you
um all right well let's get this party
started and say hello to our first
contestant bernadette
[Applause]
we're so excited to see what you are
gonna do will you tell us one thing
about yourself though first well i love
to jump rope
how many can you do like in a row how
long can you do it i can do as many like
probably up to 500 600 yes
wow
okay bernadette show us what you've got
thank you for coming today yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
like that was incredible oh thank you
i am exhausted
does anyone here
understand how physically hard that is
like i don't understand how you just
pulled that off with and seemingly with
the smile on your face super effortless
thank you well thank you bernadette
you're very much welcome
your turn fast oh right i'm so sorry
here we go please welcome our second
contestant mariah
tell us a little bit about yourself and
your talent well i'm 23 years old i'm
from staten island new york and i'm a
contortionist what yes
wow
[Applause]
this uh you know why i love
contortionists because it's so wrong
right you shouldn't bend that way no but
you do yes wow
at home are you like totally lazy and
you're like i'm turning on the tv gunk
my parents are sick of it will you show
us of course you please yes
okay thank you
already i'm impressed one knee
go out
wait a minute
what's happening
oh wow
strength
[Music]
oh god
oh my god
so far so far yeah and what happened to
your spine where'd it go
lost it long ago that was unbelievable
is there a point where you think okay i
can't do that i can't push myself that
far and then you do
yeah
yeah
and then you what go to the hospital
yeah
so far so good no hospital visits knock
on all the wood in the world mariah
[Applause]
[Music]
you